the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns in a
song of ice and fire update video in
this video i want to show you something
else george rr martin had to say during
another recent interview now if you're
someone who watches all of my videos
then you're most likely already up to
date on everything george rr martin has
said as you know i often make videos
whenever he sits down for a new
interview or when he makes his own
updates on his not a blog website after
reading almost everything he's said over
the last few years i don't think i've
ever seen him say something like this
before during this new interview he
revealed some more information about how
he will end a song of ice and fire ever
since game of thrones ended over three
years ago millions of fans have wondered
if george rr martin's novels will have
the same ending as you can imagine there
are a lot of fans who are worried about
this because they hated how dan and dave
ended game of thrones now as i'm sure
most of you already know george rr
martin has said that the way he ends his
song of ice and fire novels will be very
different from the game of thrones
ending this is something that we've
actually heard him say before i think
most of us assume that this would happen
since game of thrones left out so many
characters from the novels there was
almost no way their endings would be the
same since they left out so much
information however there are still a
lot of fans who believe the major
moments we saw happen in game of thrones
season 8 are also going to happen at the
end of a song of ice and fire the main
reason why they believe this is because
game of thrones writers david and dan
said they got george r martin's ending
after having a sit down with him years
ago now although george rr martin has
said that he doesn't like to write his
endings in advance he's always known
what would happen with most of the main
characters when game of thrones writers
david and dan met with george in his
home years ago they found out some of
the major moments in his ending as of
right now none of us actually know what
they were given the only thing that has
been confirmed was that brainstark will
become the king actor isaac hemstead
wright revealed this shortly after the
game of thrones finale he said the
writers let him know this information
was directly from george rr martin
himself ever since game of thrones aired
its final season many of us fans have
wondered what else will be written in
the novels will we see daenerys
targaryen barn king's landing or arya
stark defeat a night king at the end of
a song of ice and fire this is what
every fan wants to know
did dan and dave actually get these
ideas from george well thanks to his
recent interview it doesn't really
matter where these ideas were from even
if he did give this information to david
and dan it no longer means we will see
it happen at the end of his story george
rr martin now says whatever he did give
the game of thrones writers will not
necessarily be in his novels anymore in
the new interview they ask him if his
upcoming novels will diverge from game
of thrones he said a lot of this story
comes to me as i write it i always knew
once the show got beyond my novels which
i honestly did not anticipate they would
start going in directions that my novels
are not going to go in now as i'm
writing a song of ice and fire and i'm
making more and more progress and it's
getting longer ideas are coming to me
and characters are taking me in
directions that are even further from
where the show went
so what i think you're gonna find is
when the winds of winter and then
hopefully a dream of spring come out
that my ending will be very different
and there will be some similarities some
big moments that i gave david and dan
many years ago when they visited me in
santa fe
that was the famous meeting i was
referring to earlier when david and dan
went to his home to find out how he
would end a song of ice and fire
now george is saying this meeting only
lasted for a few days therefore he
wasn't able to give them everything he
most likely hadn't thought of everything
either since this was nearly a decade
ago
now what he says next is very
interesting and significant if you ask
me he goes on to say even some of those
things i did give them are changing as i
do the writing so they will be different
and then it'll be up to the readers and
the viewers to decide which one they
like better and argue about it you see
most of us knew the ending would be
similar because he had been saying that
for years i think most of us did assume
that those major moments he gave david
and dan would stay the same but now he's
saying otherwise
now he says what he did give them will
be different as well i can't help but
wonder if the fan's backlash to game of
thrones season 8 had some sort of effect
on his writing although he has always
said the fans would not affect his
writing i do wonder if the hatred david
and dan received made him reconsider his
ending
something that previously
maybe one reader in a thousand would
have guessed but you still had the other
999 who would have no inkling
until you reveal it in a book
now
that one person in a thousand puts it on
an internet message board and everybody
sees it and they say oh yeah yeah that's
right now i see the clues i got it and
pretty soon
half
the readership or at least the internet
savvy portion of your readership knows
it but what do you do then do you change
it and come up with something goofy and
outlandish that you haven't led the you
haven't done the the foreshadowing for
that you haven't laid the foundation for
just in order to surprise people i mean
sure i could have like aliens come down
and that would certainly
surprise the out of everybody no one is
predicting that but
it would ruin the series so
he is definitely worried about how the
fans are starting to feel in the
interview he was also asked about the
backlash and his level of concern for
the new show he said i do see comments
online from fans and sometimes they
email me directly i'm also concerned
about a similar thing with my novel as
you know the winds of winter is very
very late the last one a dance with
dragons was 11 years ago and the fans
are very angry about that now since the
fans are already angry about how late it
is imagine if he releases the ones of
winner and it had a lot of the same dumb
ideas we saw in game of thrones imagine
waiting 11 years to see the exact same
thing we already saw on the show
i think that would make a lot of the
fans very upset even if it was
incredibly well written i think he saw
how the fans reacted to the final season
of game of thrones and ultimately
decided he better go in another
direction
regardless of what actually happened or
will happen we now know for a fact that
his ending will be very different even
those moments he gave david and dan all
those years ago
that makes me think something will be
very different with how danny jon arya
and even bran are handled but i guess we
shall see as always let me know what you
think down below i want to thank all of
you for stopping by and watching my
video i hope all of you have a great day
i will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you